Speaker 1: You know, there are certain things
that are guaranteed.
One of those things is Republican hypocrisy.
Over the course of the last several decades,
it has become crystal clear in the minds of
anybody who's paid attention that Republicans
love to talk a big game.
When Democrats are in control about budgets,
they whine and cry from the rooftops.
How are we going to pay for that?
And it's not an altogether unreasonable question
if asked in good faith.
But during the presidency of Donald Trump,
the anextra seven or so trillion dollars was
added to the national debt while we were in
the midst of economic boom times a trillion
to a trillion and a half dollar deficits every
year, even when things were great, when we
should be squirreling away money for a rainy
day, preparing for a time when there would
be an economic downturn, we were we were letting
the rich off the fox into the henhouse.
The rich, all kinds of tax cuts.
Adding to the national debt.
Well, now the Democrats are in charge.
There are several proposals that they're trying
to make that they're they're forwarding in
hopes that Krysten Sinema and Joe Manchin
won't get in the way.
This New York Times article.
Senate Democrats begin three point five trillion
dollar push for big, bold social change.
A Senate budget blueprint, which Democrats
hope to pass this week, would ease passage
of legislation that would mark the biggest
expansion of the social safety net in nearly
60 years.
And this is good news, especially in the state
that we find ourselves in covid.
People on the brink of financial collapse.
Millions and millions of Americans almost
ready to be evicted from their domiciles.
Because they cannot pay their rent.
People are in crisis study after study after
study over the course of the last few years
have indicated that a large percentage of
Americans could not withstand an unexpected
400 dollar charge expense.
Things aren't great for millions of Americans,
and we need to update how we take care of
those in need reading from this article.
Democrats formally began their push on Monday
for the most significant expansion of the
nation's social safety net since the Great
Society of the 1960s, unveiling a budget blueprint
that would spend three point five trillion
dollars on health care, child and elder care,
education and climate change.
The budget resolution, which the Senate Democrats
hope to pass by the end of this week, would
allow the caucus to piece together social
policy legislation this fall paid for by raising
taxes on the wealthy, large inheritances and
corporations.
Should all 50 senators who caucus with Democrats
hold together, the measure could pass the
Senate without a Republican vote nullifying
the filibuster threat.
Democrats plan to take up the measure as soon
as the Senate approves a separate one trillion
dollar bipartisan infrastructure bill, which,
by the way, is a far cry from the multitrillion
dollar infrastructure proposal that Biden
wanted.
Why one?
Because of the recalcitrant Joe Manchin, the
aforementioned Joe Manchin, but also because
Republicans.
They're not in the business of getting things
done, they're in the business of opposition.
The one trillion dollar bipartisan infrastructure
bill, which is scheduled for a vote at 11:00
a.m. Tuesday.
Together, the measures could secure virtually
all of President Biden's four trillion dollar
economic agenda, rebuilding the nation's roads,
bridges, rail lines, water systems and electricity
grid while expanding public education, social
welfare and health care and remaking the federal
tax code that is important.
Democrats are hard at work, bobbing and weaving
and dodging the arrows of Republicans who
aren't in the business of progress.
And Democrats are trying to get something
done for the American people to update our
country, to refresh the way we do things.
Because if this is the largest, the largest,
the biggest expansion of Social Security,
the social safety net in nearly 60 years,
what are we doing?
If we're allowing Republicans to completely
control the narrative like we have for for
a generation on the minimum wage.
What are we doing if we we want to claim we
live in modernity, we need to start acting
like it, we need to start leading like it,
we need to start legislating like it.
If the Congress can make all kinds of exceptions
because of covid to update their voting proxy
rules, we certainly can do that surrounding
this and allowing Republicans to get in the
way, especially where it relates to the filibuster.
Isn't leadership.
If you ask me, it's cowardice